eu comecei a minha vida de atleta com
apenas um ano de idade
minha mãe me colocou na natação muito
cedo e eu sempre amei vivem nas piscinas
nas águas e eu passei por outros outros
esportes porque exercícios físicos
sempre foi algo natural para mim quando
eu tinha 18 anos eu descobri que eu
tinha hipotireoidismo uma disfunção
hormonal que te deixa de indisposição
que faz ganhar peso e as vezes que faz
cair em depressão
eu cheguei a a engordar 15 quilos em
cinco meses e que ainda pensam algumas
vezes isso não ajuda muito na autoestima
de um adolescente que meio desengonçado
aqui sempre que nunca se sentiu à
vontade na sua própria pele
eu cresci e me tornei o tipo de mulher
que chamava a atenção por onde passava
mas a gente sempre reclama de aula nada
alimentava minha vaidade eu continuava
sem me sentir à vontade no meu próprio
corpo
eu também não tinha sonhos eu não tinha
um propósito pra vida e eu procurava
balancear isso com minha personalidade é
muito teimosa é muito determinada e
brincalhona mas já em 2013 depois de
passar depois de uma reguladora da minha
da minha do meu hipotireoidismo
eu ganhei alguns quilos extras eu passei
um tempo sem treinar e eu entrei em uma
neura de que eu precisava ter o corpo
perfeito pra me senti bem
eu estava começando a entrar em
depressão e e fiquei nessa eu achava que
eu precisava chegar aquele meu corpo dos
sonhos pra que tudo ficasse no lugar e
eu nunca estive tão enganada dana
holding viu sabe quando a gente precisa
de uma queda na vida pra se dar conta do
que realmente importa
eu caí de verdade e aí no dia 4 de
outubro de 2013
eu comecei
a batalha da minha vida já cansada do
treino mas sempre querendo superar os
limites do meu corpo eu fiz um exercício
que não devia
nessa hora eu bati o braço ea cabeça num
caixote de madeira que estava embaixo de
mim e thaís sentada
eu tentava me levantar eu não conseguia
a dor começou a tomar conta do meu corpo
e tudo começou a queimar mesmo por
dentro mas eu não sentia minhas pernas
eu tentava não não me desesperar eu
tentava manter a calma eu não chorava
mas eu sabia que alguma coisa estava
errada
era uma dor que eu nunca pensei que
pudesse que pudesse existir após passar
por dois hospitais e alguns médicos
diferentes prognóstico não foi dos
melhores
eu havia sofrido uma uma fatura de
explosão na região lombar da minha
coluna e essa fratura quebrou a vértebra
l1 diversos pedaços e atirou dois
fechando a medula ia bem em menos de 50%
e como todo mundo sabe a medula que
controla todo o funcionamento e
movimentação do corpo
eu fiquei paralisada da cintura pra
baixo
eu havia ficado paraplégica e pela
gravidade da lesão os médicos todos
foram unânimes em dizer que eu nunca
mais andaria eles disseram isso pra mim
e essa altura já não mexer meu tronco
estava difícil de levantar os braços do
ia pra mexer a cabeça
eu precisava da ajuda de outras pessoas
para escovar os dentes a me alimentar
para fazer qualquer tipo de necessidade
pra mexer no cabelo se eu precisasse mas
eu estava anestesiada
eu preferia nem pensar no que estava
acontecendo
não era algo muito fácil de se ver e
muito menos se viver mas eu continuo eu
continuava de bombons em primeiro é eu
passei depois de 23 dias
fiz a primeira cirurgia cirurgia de
correção e colocou duas hastes 12
parafusos e uma ponte de titânio ao
redor da minha coluna para sustentá la
e no outro dia o cirurgião chegou no meu
quarto e disse que estava surpreso com o
procedimento com a cirurgia ele disse
que meus ossos eram muito rígidos
rígidos tão rígidos
é por causa da minha vida de atleta
alimentação saudável mas eles eram tão
rígidos que havia dificultado a cirurgia
mas também por causa dessa rigidez eles
protegerão minha medula e por um milagre
ela não foi perfurada
ela havia sido muito comprimida mas eu
teria chances de voltar a andar mas
provavelmente demoraria dois anos ou
mais
eu passei um mês no hospital nesse um
mês eu comecei um blog que passar o meu
tempo livre assim eu contava minhas
alegrias minhas tristezas minhas dores
davam as palhaçadas também e isso serviu
de terapia para mim serviu também de
terapia para outras pessoas que
começaram a acompanhar meu blog e se
inspiravam na minha luta
esse feedback serviu de combustível para
mim e não me deixava de existir mas
depois da primeira cirurgia descobri que
estava com infecção nos ossos e
hemorragia interna
meu corpo não estava reagindo e o corte
não fechava e todos os dias o médico
chegava no meu quarto para apertar ou
furar em volta do corte de tirar o
sangue que estava acumulando e doía
muito que ele fazia e sem anestesia
nenhum mas eu não chorava
eu continuava preferindo não sentir eu
eu não queria chorar e a minha o meu
estado havia passado de grave é
gravíssimo
era tão grave essa infecção que eu tive
que sentar
com três tipos diferentes de antibiótico
por 75 dias
os médicos não se preocupavam mais eu ia
voltar a andar se eu ia voltar a mexer
alguma coisa agora dúvida era se eu ia
sobreviver aqui o e foi somente quando
eu me permite sentir quando eu me
permiti chorar se notar perceber que a
minha vida havia mudado foi que o meu
corpo reagiu e quando ele reagiu
o corte começou a fechar recebi alta
depois de um mês e eu fiquei
extremamente feliz porque depois de um
mês eu ia voltar pra minha casa meu
quarto ea cama meu deus não estava feliz
mas eu estava enganada
tudo era diferente quando eu voltei à
minha cama não era mais minha cama ela
havia sido substituída por uma cama
hospitalar minha antiga cadeira de rodas
não passava pelas portas da minha casa e
meu quarto era no primeiro andar que é o
que realmente eu não conseguia chegar é
pelas escadas porque eu continuava
paraplégica e aí na minha história eu
contei com a ajuda de alguns anjos
um deles foi felipe o felipe me carregar
pelas escadas sempre que eu precisasse a
hora que fosse e nos braços do meu amigo
felipe
eu subi as escadas e cheguei no meu
quarto
naquela primeira noite eu posso dizer
sem sombra de dúvidas de que foi a pior
da minha vida eu não conseguia dormir
eu me sentia sufocada naquela cama
hospitalar
eu não conseguia respirar eu só sentia
que estava no hospital de novo eu sentia
todas as dores e eu só esperei clarear
pra pedir pelo amor de deus pra minha
mãe me tirar dali e saindo do meu quarto
sendo carregada pelos meus pais e pela
minha irmã eu dei de cara com um espelho
mas eu não me reconhece eu estava batida
é provavelmente um mês sem dormir
direito dias sem banho
e ali caiu a ficha de verdade
ali eu genuinamente pensei que era
melhor morrer do que fazer minha família
passar por aquilo e ali eu me dei conta
que a agenda que eu conhecia ela morreu
naquela queda de 4 de outubro
e eu sou renasce dois dias depois desse
dessa alta depois da visita de mais um
anjo da minha história
serginho o fisioterapeuta que me ensinou
a mentalizar o movimento que eu queria e
tanto tentar e depois de muito tentar eu
conseguir pela primeira vez movimentos
involuntários dos meus dedos do pé
como vocês podem ver não foi muito mas
aquilo foi o suficiente para me dar
forças para lutar
foi aí que ressurgiu maria geny a mais
forte mas determinada muito mais teimosa
era daquele raio de esperança que eu
precisava pra seguir em frente e começar
essa minha nova vida e esse dia foi tão
importante pra mim que eu fiz questão de
tatuar no meu braço junto com a frase
quem acredita sempre alcança trecho da
música que virou hino para a minha
família nos momentos difíceis no dia 3
de novembro de 2013
o marcado pra sempre pra mim porque
aquele exato momento era maior exemplo é
o exemplo perfeito dessa frase quem
acredita sempre alcança e aí de tanto
querer de tanto sonhar
a nova maria gênia depois de terem dito
que ela nunca mais voltaria a andar
ela levantou de sua cadeira arrastando
seus papéis pelo chão
ela deu seus primeiros passos
meus médicos acreditavam o meu médico -
cirurgião aquele que diz que eu tinha
chance de voltar a andar
a primeira vez que eu entrei no
consultório dele com um andador
ele olhou pra mim credo e disse não era
pra você tá assim mas eu me esforçava o
máximo possível todos os dias para
surpreender a todos e principalmente a
mim e ao mesmo tempo que isso acontecia
eu travava uma batalha muito grande com
a minha mente para aceitar toda aquela
reviravolta que tinha acontecido na
minha vida eu me incomodava com os
comentários quando eu saía eu me
incomodava conjunto com os olhares eu
encaminho incomodava com a vida sobre
uma cadeira de rodas
eu me incomodava com a idade que eu
havia perdido o meu cabelo que era na
cintura caiu bastante e eu tive que
cortar no o na altura do ombro porque
estava enganchado no curativo
as minhas pernas antes grossas e
musculosas agora finas atrofiados e
flácidas só perigoso
a minha cicatriz a primeira vez que eu
vi minha cicatriz no espelho aquele
mesmo espelho da primeira noite ele teve
um ataque de pânico ela era horrível eu
achava que eu não aceitava a minha
aparência porque eu acreditava que a
sociedade não aceitava ela mais uma vez
eu estava enganada e aí é eu comecei com
um anjo em forma de psicóloga batalha a
terapia que me trouxe o processo de
aceitação
eu tive que parar de tentar encontrar um
sentido naquilo tudo porque eu não iria
encontrar nunca teve que enxergar a
pessoa que eu havia me tornado
eu estava muito mais forte eu havia
prendido o real valor da vida eu tava
mais amorosa mais próxima da minha
família que é descoberto que eu que é
muito mais muito mais amigos do que eu
saiba que estavam sempre do meu lado eu
havia me tornado exemplo para tanta
gente que via a minha luta e via como eu
havia encarado tudo aquilo de peito
aberto
a única coisa que me incomodava era
memória da queda daquele momento e
marcou mas eu fiz uma promessa e cumpri
fiz uma promessa a mim mesmo quando fiz
um ano do acidente eu comemorei com a
caminhada que eu chamei de meu primeiro
quilômetro de tanto que eu correria e aí
andando nos braços dos meus amigos do e
alguns conhecidos da minha família e até
alguns desconhecidos que me acompanhavam
pelo blog eu pude tirar toda aquela
carga negativa que eu tinha do dia 4 de
outubro
e aí eu usei me olhar no espelho
novamente e aí eu vi que eu não tinha
como eu ainda não tenho corpo perfeito
eu andava com uma muleta como eu ainda
andando mas eu tenho um orgulho enorme
de tudo o que eu havia vivido e de como
entrar e tudo de cabeça erguida com
sorriso no rosto
sem medo de nada e aí eu pude ver que eu
aceitava essa agenda do espelho eu me
achava linda e eu pude é ver isso mais
ainda com a ajuda de outro anjo chamada
carolina que fez o ensaio você tem que
fazer um ensaio sensual para me mostrar
que eu não deixei de ser linda com tudo
o que me aconteceu pelo contrário me
achar ainda mais bonita hoje a minha
cicatriz virou o maior troféu que eu
podia ter ganho na vida eu
aprendi mais em três anos de luta contra
lesão medular do que em 27 sem nenhuma
deficiência
eu aprendi que a mente que deixa o corpo
forte não o contrário foi minha mente
que me fez superar e vencer todas essas
batalhas que virão pela frente
eu eu vi na superação a minha maior
felicidade
eu caí disseram que eu nunca mais me
levantaria mas eu não sou me levantei
como eu andei eu matei eu não sei eu
agachei eu subi desse escada de eu
levantei peso
hoje eu aprendi a sonhar eu voltei para
as águas de uma forma diferente
eu já sou para atletas de remo com o
sonho olímpico
e eu ganhei um propósito na vida ser
resiliente
obrigada